-Disgraced crypto mogul
Sam Bankman-Fried
has been arrested and charged
with eight criminal counts,
including wire fraud,
securities fraud,
and money laundering
after the collapse
of his crypto exchange, FTX.
The arrest comes after
right-wing pundits spent weeks
speculating
that the Justice Department
would never hold
SBF accountable
because he donated to Democrats,
and now Republicans
have moved on to a new,
completely contradictory
conspiracy theory.
They're claiming
the arrest of SBF
was just a ploy to keep him
from testifying to Congress.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Even if you don't know or don't
care that much about crypto,
you've probably
heard of this guy,
Sam Bankman-Fried,
who was, until recently,
one of crypto's
biggest rising stars.
Maybe you heard about
his crypto exchange, FTX,
or is trading firm,
Alameda Research,
or maybe you just
caught wind of the fact
that one of the biggest
rising stars in tech and finance
was a guy who looks
the way Cheeto dust smells.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, lookit --
that dude looks like
an Albuquerque
dog walker at 6:00 a.m.
"Come on, Nacho, buddy.
Do your business, bro."
[ Laughter ]
He looks like he should be
playing Seth Rogan's burnout son
in a Judd Apatow movie.
[ Laughter ]
Somehow, this guy tricked the
world's most influential people
into believing
he was a crypto visionary.
Most international criminals
have ice water
in their veins,
not bong water.
And yet he even managed
to convince
the likes of Bill Clinton
and Tony Blair
to appear on stage with him
at a conference in the Bahamas
where FTX was based.
I mean, look at the disparity
between them.
Here's a tip --
if you ever find yourself
sitting on a stage
in the Bahamas in a suit
and you look around and notice
you're sitting to someone
who's dressed like they forgot
to change after gym class,
that should br your first clue
you [bleep] up.
[ Laughter ]
There was a time when these two
were both regarded
as political trailblazers
and master tacticians,
but I think that all goes
out the window
once you get hoodwinked
into appearing on stage
with the Hobbit
who stayed behind...
[ Laughter ]
...in the Shire because
he was busy playing Wii Tennis.
True story, you guys.
SBF was in a deleted scene
in "Lord of the Rings"
where he pitches the Fellowship
on a crypto exchange,
and even Gollum is like,
"No, thanks. I'll pass."
[ Laughter ]
"Smeagol also thinks
it smells funny."
[ Laughter ]
Actually, that deleted-scene
thing's not a true story,
because if you're familiar
with "Lord of the Rings,"
you know, they didn't
delete any scenes.
[ Laughter ]
It's the only movie
where the extended version
is somehow shorter.
Anyway, it turns out
it was all a lie.
In a hearing, FTX's new C.E.O.
said the company had committed
what he called
"old-fashioned embezzlement."
FTX's balance sheet was
allegedly just a house of cards,
and now it's all come
crashing down.
-Breaking news --
Sam Bankman-Fried,
the founder of the failed
cryptocurrency exchange FTX,
has been arrested in the Bahamas
just one month
after the spectacular collapse
of his company.
-The Securities and Exchange
Commission says Bankman-Fried
is charged with
defrauding customers
out of billions of dollars
and orchestrating a massive,
years-long fraud.
They also say he diverted
billions of dollars
from the customer funds
for his own personal benefit.
-Billions of dollars
have not been accounted for
since FTX collapsed.
-Oh, are
billions of dollars missing?
Have you checked the fanny pack
where his weed dealer
keeps all his tips?
"Whoa! SBF gave me
a billion-dollar tip.
Looks like someone's getting
new beaded curtains."
[ Laughter ]
Sal wrote that joke,
so if you're wondering
if Sal smokes weed,
the answer is a resounding no.
[ Laughter ]
His reference for a weed dealer
is beaded curtains,
which I think he got from, what,
an old "Dragnet" episode?
[ Laughter ]
That joke technically counts
as a clean drug test.
[ Laughter ]
Sal, you know what weed dealers
have these days?
Cashiers.
All right, buddy?
Also, I can't believe this guy
thought he could hide out
in the Bahamas.
Usually when you think
of international fugitive,
you imagine
a stylish jewel thief,
not a dude in a T-shirt
that clearly came out
of a cannon
at a basketball game.
I mean, dude was supposed
to be a billionaire,
but he looks like he was
thrown naked into a Goodwill
and given 90 seconds
to get dressed.
Now, again, just to give you
an idea of how much of a scam
SBF's crypto exchange
allegedly was,
the new CEO, who has been
installed to clean things up
after SBF's fall from grace,
is the same guy who came in
to clean up Enron
after its collapse in 2001.
And in addition to accusing
FTX of embezzlement,
that guy also said recently...
You know it's bad
when even the guy
who had to clean up
the Enron scandal is horrified.
The only way
this could get any worse
is if we found out that --
I don't know --
one of the key proponents
of the Iraq war
was somehow connected to --
oh [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
Also, once again,
why did it take
until now for someone
to figure out that this dude
was grossly inexperienced
and unsophisticated?
Look, I know I'm hosting
a network television show
dressed like I'm about
to go cut down
the Rockefeller Christmas tree,
but...
[ Laughter ]
...wasn't it nice
when con artists
put a little more thought
into their outfits?
I mean, in "Music Man,"
Harold Hill had a straw hat
and a nice bow tie,
so when he ripped off,
you didn't have to feel bad
about getting tricked.
But now it's all, "I dress
like a record producer,"
or, "I dress like Steve Jobs,"
or, "I dress like the kid
at the skate park
who has the most expensive board
but just stands
against the fence,
not doing any tricks."
Anyway...
[ Laughter ]
Part of the reason
SBF's companies were scams
is that a significant portion
of the balance sheet
was reportedly held
in a new crypto token
they themselves just made up.
They just made it up
and pretended it was valuable.
I mean,
try that sometime yourself.
See how that goes.
It won't work.
Unless you invest
in my new crypto token,
Seth Coin.
[ Laughter ]
Seth Coin
is an innovative new currency
that allows you to take control
of your financial future.
To get started,
simply wire all of your money
to the routing number
listed below, and voilà!
You'll be able to pay
all your bills,
like your rent or your
utilities, in Seth Coin.
And if your landlord doesn't
accept Seth Coin as payment,
just show him a picture of me
dressed like this,
and I think...
[ Laughter ]
...he'll change his tune.
-Seth! Seth! I'd like to buy
one of your Seth Coins.
-You would?
-Yes.
And I will give you
10 Wally bucks for it.
You got a deal...
-...sucker.
-Sucker.
[ Laughter ]
SBF also tried very hard
to ingratiate himself
with politicians,
and he cozied up
to power brokers
in both parties.
He reportedly spent $40 million
on the midterms,
mostly to help Democrats,
although he claimed
in an interview
that he gave about
the same amount
to Republicans through
unaccountable dark money.
Nonetheless, the donations
led many right-wingers
to speculate the Democrats
and the Biden administration
would never hold
SBF accountable,
like Twitter C.E.O. Elon Musk,
who said last month,
"SBF was a major Dem donor,
so no investigation."
But, hey, if there's anything
we've learned about Elon Musk
since he bought Twitter,
it's that the man
is always right.
Like when he changed
Twitter's verification system
and accidentally allowed people
to imitate brands
which somehow led to Super Mario
telling me to go [bleep] myself.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, why?
Because I said
Peach was too good for you?
Oh!
Then why do you keep
letting her get kidnapped
by a [bleep] turtle?
[ Laughter ]
So, Musk got that one wrong.
And to add insult to injury,
he also reportedly lost his spot
as the world's richest man
the same week it was reported
that Twitter hasn't paid rent
on its offices in weeks.
I'm sorry, Elon.
Guess you should have invested
in Seth Coin
when you had the chance.
So that was
the first conspiracy theory --
Democrats would never
investigate SBF
because he donated to them.
But now that SBF
has been arrested,
Republicans have moved on
to a second conspiracy theory.
The arrest was actually
just a ploy to stop SBF
from testifying at a House
hearing on Tuesday.
-Why is the Biden
Justice Department,
why are they filing charges
and seeking this extradition
before he had the opportunity
to testify tomorrow?
Why wouldn't they
want him to testify?
-Congressman Lee Zeldin
telling Fox News,
"House Republicans were ready
to grill him six ways to Sunday.
Now breaking tonight,"
meaning last night,
"SBF was just arrested.
Why not allow him
to first testify tomorrow
and answer our many questions
under oath?"
-You know, there are a lot of
people scratching their heads.
They're saying,
"Why would they arrest him
before
he could actually testify?"
He has donated tens of millions
of dollars to Democrats.
And under oath,
he would have to ask --
Mr. Zeldin would ask
embarrassing questions
of the Democrats
and of that crypto king.
And so isn't it convenient
that the prosecutors stepped in
and charged him
before he could sit down
in front of Capitol Hill?
-All right. First of all,
I doubt Joe Biden
had any involvement
in this case.
And the way I know that is,
he's 80 years old.
He probably has no idea
what crypto is or how it works.
I mean,
I don't even really know,
and I'm only in my late 70s.
You guys think...
[ Laughter ]
...think I'm young
because of my youthful charm.
But when I take my makeup off
after the show,
I look like I'm in Disney's
Hall of Presidents.
[ Laughter ]
At least that guy wears a suit.
Also, the idea that Biden
somehow stopped Congress
from getting to the bottom
of what happened with FTX
is absurd.
You really think Congress
is going to ask penetrating
questions about cryptocurrency?
You guys think
89-year-old Chuck Grassley
is really gonna
crack the case on crypto?
I'm sure he still prefers to pay
for everything
with beaver pelts.
[ Laughter ]
This is a man who once tweeted,
as a sitting
United States senator,
"I now h v an iPhone."
[ Laughter ]
You really think that same man
who tweeted that
would grill Bankman-Fried
on anything other
than his appearance?
"Listen to me, young man.
There are cameras here
so you go get yourself a tie
and a haircut, and then I'll
ask my questions about --
Where was it?
Hold on.
The blockchain?
That can't be right.
Those are just two other words
smashed together.
It's a currency exchange?
Like those airport kiosks?
Those things are a rip-off.
I went to Italy in '72.
I still have my lira because of
how hard they tried to screw me.
Should we take a break
for lunch?
I'll have two soups."
[ Laughter ]
Any time Congress holds hearings
about anything tech-related,
it's a disaster,
as we've discussed
from previous hearings
on Facebook or Google.
They don't even know the first
thing about modern technology.
-How do you sustain
a business model
in which users
don't pay for your service?
-Senator, we run ads.
-I have a 7-year-old
granddaughter
who picked up her phone
before the election,
and she's playing a little game,
kind of game a kid would play,
and up on there pops a picture
of her grandfather.
And I'm not going to say
into the record
what kind of language
was used around
that picture of her grandfather,
but I'd ask you,
how does that show up
on a 7-year-old's iPhone
who's playing a kids game?
-Congressman, iPhone is made
by a different company,
and so, you know, I mean...
-It might've been an Android.
It's just -- it was
a hand-me-down of some kind.
-"It might have been
an iPhone or an Android,
or maybe it was a Fisher-Price.
Whenever I -- Whenever
I turned it on, it played
'Twinkle, Twinkle, Little Star.'
Does that help?"
So Republicans and Fox News
went from claiming Democrats
wouldn't investigate SBF
because they're corrupt
to SBF only got arrested
because Biden's corrupt.
None of it makes any sense,
of course.
The reality is,
the FTX collapse
was evidence
of a broader failure
the entire political
and financial world
needs to reckon with.
Although I have my doubts
that Republicans in Congress
will get to the bottom of it,
these guys can barely figure out
how to play "Candy Crush" on...
-...a 7-year-old's iPhone.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]